i'm delighted
to offer my congratulations to mr ranjit
sindisal from india
upon winning the 2020 global teacher
prize
today the world comes together to honor
the enormous courage and self-sacrifice
of teachers
during this time of uncertainty
at the time when education suffered the
largest disruption in history of
humanity
it is greatly heartening to see the
determination of teachers around the
world
to keep learning alive
nothing can substitute a good teacher
and especially now when we're looking at
the immense
challenges of the post-covic 19 recovery
it is critical that the world continues
to support
teachers in their vital work
i truly believe that teachers have never
met
more than they do today as i have said
many times before the united nations
and unesco's task is to build a 21st
century
that is more peaceful more inclusive
more just and more sustainable
and this cannot happen without
teachers teachers like ranjit sin
are the key to unlocking the future we
want
thank you and congratulations again